donc fin de 27 heures les chaînes c'est
très précis c'est une visite Madeleine
de 27 heures si on les compare aux
autres visites dans l'histoire
est-ce que il y a eu du de la bonne
besoin d'effectuer il y a quand même une
annonce sur vaxam premier tour de table
Madeleine je commence avec vous
est-ce que on peut dire mission
accomplie du côté d'Ottawa
absolument Patrice absolument parce
qu'on a eu cette entente sur le chemin
Roxane c'était devenu un problème
politique pour Justin Trudeau la
situation devenait intenable
premièrement il y avait François Legault
qui mettait de plus en plus de pression
disons que la capacité d'accueil du
Canada du Québec plutôt était atteint la
l'immigrants commençait à être répartis
dans les autres provinces canadiennes la
pression risquait de venir d'ailleurs
non seulement il y avait la pression
difficulté d'accueillir ces gens mais
aussi c'était tout le système
d'immigration qui était mise en cause
les gens qui commençaient à peut-être
avoir moins confiance dans le système
officiel emprunter des portes par en
arrière pour essayer de rentrer au pays
le chemin Roxane était publicité à
travers le monde on avait 40
000 migrants qui étaient passés par là
l'année passée ça semble une goutte
d'eau par rapport à la frontière sud des
États-Unis mais pour le Canada ça
devenait un problème politique je dis
bien politique important pour Justin
Trudeau donc Joe Biden lui a en faveur
en réglant ce problème politique on
s'est demandé s'il y aurait une
contrepartie s'il devrait Justin Trudeau
donner quelque chose en échange à Joe
Biden il y a une aide qui est offerte à
Haïti mais sinon ça ne lui a pas coûté
très cher je vous dirais cette ce
règlement du dossier de du chemin Roxane
ou de la frontière entre Canada et les
États-Unis ouais Michel c'est Raphaël
hier l'ambassadeur chrétien me disait
nous disait il y a un donnant donnant on
va s'apercevoir qu'il y a quelque chose
on s'est aperçu qu'il y avait pas
tellement de Donna donna
Madeleine parle de faveur Michel C
êtes-vous d'accord
je suis certainement un beau couple
c'est certainement un cadeau que
monsieur baiden a fait en même temps il
y a quand même un petit tenant petit qui
est que le Canada va accueillir 15000
immigrants réfugiés ça c'est pas clair
de plus venant de l'hémisphère ouest on
peut comprendre par le contexte que
lisez beaucoup Canada il faisait
beaucoup Haïti là-dedans
mais pour l'ensemble ce qui est clair
c'est que dans l'ensemble de la relation
entre le Canada les États-Unis ça va
bien les deux peuvent dire bah là on est
on s'est rencontré on a réglé des
problèmes on a réussi on a une des plus
belles relations que deux pays peuvent
avoir alors pour Monsieur Trudeau
évidemment c'est du bonbon et même pour
Monsieur Biden dans une situation où la
situation internationale et est instable
dans au même la situation économique est
instable savoir qu'on a au nord un ami
sur et qui qui est comptable la relation
c'est quand même un plus oui Raphaël
Jacob le dernier président parce qu'il
faut rappeler que on a attendu le Canada
attendu deux ans plus de deux ans avec
Monsieur Baden vienne sur place le
dernier président qui est venu au Canada
c'est dans leur chambre à La Malbaie
lors d'un G7 et ça c'était fini de façon
catastrophique alors vous avez compare
on se dit bon dieu que c'est plus facile
pour Ottawa de voir venir de gérer les
dossiers avec quelqu'un comme Biden
qu'avec Trump votre question de dépasse
c'est de savoir dans une perspective
historique à quel point est-ce qu'on
peut conclure la journée d'aujourd'hui
en disant on a fait de la besogne on a
fait avancer des dossiers ça a été
fructueux tout est relatif si on regarde
où la barre avait été laissé par le
dernier président Monsieur Trump à
Charlevoix en 2018 effectivement c'était
tellement bas qu'on a très très
largement excédé disons ce qu'on avait
pu créer comme attendre la visite de
Monsieur Trump en même temps je vous
dirais qu'on a quand même mis dans la
longue histoire des relations à Canada
américaines des sommets plus importants
on a simplement à penser pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale et ça je pense
que c'est à ce jour encore assez méconnu
du public mais c'est remarquable à
Québec le président Roosevelt s'est
entretenu avec le Premier ministre
canadien ainsi qu'avec Weston Churchill
et on avait planifié notamment ce qui
était éventuellement devenu le
débarquement de Normandie en 1944 donc
on s'entend on est loin de Québec c'est
ça donc on est loin de ça quelque part
je dirais entre les deux mais d'un point
de vue diplomatique je râcherai
peut-être sur ce Michel vient de dire
c'est à dire que d'abord avant tout
l'objectif de la rencontre en fait des
rencontres d'aujourd'hui c'était
symbolique c'était d'envoyer un message
d'unité à la fois du côté canadien sur
principalement du côté canadien dans un
moindre garde du côté américain comme
quoi on a un partenariat une amitié
extrêmement forte et extrêmement
spéciale on la prend peut-être trop pour
acquis justement parce qu'on on l'a
toujours connu mais la réalité c'est
qu'on partage la frontière la plus
importante terrestre tout au moins là de
deux pays à la grandeur de la planète
c'est le plus important partenariat
commercial et à plusieurs égards c'est
peut-être la plus la plus ou une des
plus importantes amitiée de la planète
également en deux démocraties donc le
simple fait de venir renouveler son vœu
ses vœux d'amitié là c'est pas inutile
et effectivement sur le fond il y a
quand même une victoire surtout du côté
canadien d'un point de vue politique
pour Monsieur Trudeau d'avoir obtenu
cette concession
tout ce qu'on en sait pour l'instant
avec somme toute assez peu en retour
comme le soulignait Madeleine bon on a
entendu monsieur Poirier avec vous
Madeleine dire
à Monsieur un peu avait réussi à mettre
de côté le différent du bois d'oeuvre
d'exclure le Canada pendant un certain
nombre d'années
sur le front du protectionnisme qui est
une grande enveloppe et inclus là-dedans
les craintes des
du Canada que toutes les tous les
investissements dans la nouvelle
économie verte pour les batteries tout
ça serait tellement attiré vers les
États-Unis qui resterait plus pour le
Canada entre autres
j'inclus le bail americanac qui fait que
les contrats sont donnés à des
entreprises américaines d'un contrat
public est-ce que là il y a eu des des
paroles qui peuvent réconforter les
milieux d'affaires Canadiens Madeleine
il y a eu des paroles qui ont été
prononcées ça c'est certain Joe Biden
par exemple en point de presse devant
les médias canadiens et américains a dit
je suis pas je suis superplexe par
rapport à ces craintes qu'on entend dans
le milieu des affaires au Canada
notamment justement à l'effet que les
investissements dans le inflation arts
billes qui permet d'investir massivement
on parle de 370 milliards de dollars en
investissement pour faire le virage vert
aux États-Unis de quelle façon ces
investissements là finalement
pénaliserait le Canada il dit je suis
perplexe le Canada fait partie de la
solution le Canada fait partie de la
solution entre autres avec ces minéraux
critiques et si vous voulez transformer
les minéraux critiques chez vous au
Canada faites-le vous pouvez avoir un
apport bonifié avec vos ressources
naturelles donc ce sont des mots qui ont
été prononcés est-ce que ça va être
rassurant en partie j'ai quand même
l'impression que la communauté faire
surveiller oui le discours de Joe byton
la visite officielle mais aussi va
surveiller étroitement ce qui se passe
mardi prochain c'est le dépôt du budget
de Christophe willeand et elle a dit
qu'un des piliers de ce budget serait
justement des investissements aussi dans
l'économie verte on parle de crédit
d'impôts peut-être là pour des
entreprises qui feraient un virage vert
donc ça aussi ça va faire partie de
l'équation donc en ce moment la
communauté d'affaires n'a pas toutes les
pièces du casse-tête à savoir est-ce
qu'on va être en mesure de concurrencer
ou non ces investissements massifs qui
se passent aux États-Unis ok sur ça sur
la grande question du protectionnisme
qu'est-ce qu'on peut en dire ce soir
Raphaël je pense qu'il y a une chose
qu'on devrait spécifier d'emblée toute
la journée j'ai entendu des intervenants
en fait surtout des politiciens
entremêlés les termes by American et by
America on ne parle pas des mêmes choses
donc peut-être me permettre là une
seconde de pédagogie
américaine c'est ce dont on devrait
parler on fait à la loi de 1933 qui
était passé à toute fin de
l'administration Roover qui est beaucoup
plus générale lorsqu'on parle de
protectionnisme dans une énorme partie
de l'économie américaine on parle de by
American on entendait il y a un instant
d'ailleurs je pense que c'est l'entrevue
que Madeleine a eu de Monsieur paullière
by America ce n'est pas du tout la même
chose by américain on fait référence à
une autre loi celle de 1982 qui avait
été adopté son administration Reagan qui
est beaucoup beaucoup plus limitée et
qui touche c'est un noir est bonne
spécifiquement au secteur des transports
donc ça c'est une chose donc si on se
concentre sur le by American c'est une
loi il faut toujours le rappeler à
partir du moment où c'est une loi c'est
la législation ça a été adoptée par le
Congrès il y a seulement le congrat
américain qui a le pouvoir de l'abréger
ou de l'amander c'est vrai que le
président a une certaine latitude au
niveau réglementaire pour accorder des
exemples mais je pense que ça marche
relief d'abord et avant tout c'est que
la relation commerciale entre les
États-Unis et le Canada elle est forte
elle est stable et s'il y a des
irritants c'est pas vrai que le
président des États-Unis de nos jours
avec le seul acteur qui peut les régler
de 1 et ce n'est pas vrai non plus
surtout lorsqu'il vient déjà de faire
une concession dans un dossier qui était
important pour le Canada que lors du
même sommet qui sèche l'âne sur quoi
quelqu'un 27 heures exactement il va en
faire à droite et à gauche sur une
panoplie
exactement donc personnellement c'est ce
que je retiens du point de vue
protectionniste ça sera pour une autre
occasion et on va en avoir d'autres
occasions parce que le nouvel accord de
libre-échange candidate du Mexique devra
être renouvelé d'ici les trois
prochaines années donc des sommets pour
en reparler on va en avoir et on va
devoir en avoir parce qu'on répète
toujours les mêmes choses parfois Michel
les démocrates sont plus
protectionnistes les républicains
républicains et plus facile puis à mon
année c'est ce n'est pas aussi simple
que ça là Michel non d'abord les
démocrates sont beaucoup moins
protectionnistes qui l'ont déjà été
c'était vrai dans le temps où le
mouvement syndical était le Parti
démocrate presque au complet ce n'est
plus le cas alors ça c'est une chose qui
est qui est réglée d'autre part
on s'en est toujours accommoder au
Canada et dire oh c'est la source de
tous nos problèmes et si on n'avait pas
ça on pourra avoir un vrai libre-échange
et tout et tout et pourquoi pas une
union douanière minute là ça se passe
pas comme ça ça a été suffisamment
difficile de renégocier l'ALENA on ne
faut pas penser qu'on va recommencer ça
à toutes les deux ans juste pour faire
plaisir aux Chambres de commerce et j'ai
quand même plus loin que ça c'est pas
juste qu'on le fera pas c'est que pour
le Canada à chaque fois qu'on roule ses
ententes là il y a un peu exact et il y
a beaucoup plus à perdre du côté
canadien que du côté américain c'est pas
pour rien que lorsque dans mon champ est
arrivé au pouvoir c'est un Mexico et
Ottawa qu'on résistait autant pour
rouvrir
l'ALENA parce qu'on se dit écoutez nos
économies dépendent tellement des des
exportations aux États-Unis c'est vrai
pour le Canada je sais que c'est encore
plus vrai pour le Mexique que pour les
États-Unis on avait beaucoup à gagner
beaucoup moins à perdre donc il y a ça à
garder en tête également pour tous ceux
qui se disent on doit rouvrir
on doit rouvrir si attention attention
exactement et gardons en tête la chance
qu'on a d'avoir un marché aussi solide à
nos portes et aussi riches que celui que
sont les États-Unis d'Amérique et les
Américains ont des doléances aussi vous
avez du Canada les produits laitiers et
tout ça ça les énerve depuis 1000 ans
alors ça va pas que dans un sens il est
important de l'un et l'autre ne va pas
que dans un sens aussi pour combien
d'états le premier client et le Canada
il y en a plusieurs donc
il doit faire attention aussi
écoutez quand on a commencé à renégocier
l'ALENA qu'est-ce que le Canada a fait
il y a publié 50 fiches pour chacun des
États voici le nombre d'emplois qui sont
qui dépendent du Canada voici le
commerce qu'on entre les deux et ils ont
dit passer par-dessus l'administration
Trump allez voir les gouverneurs allez
voir des sénateurs aller voir les
représentants et c'est une stratégie qui
est assez bien marché au moment donné
dans les états
le Wisconsin aime pas beaucoup les les
tiers au Canada mais en même temps il y
a plein de dans le secteur automobile il
y a plein de de d'emplois qui dépendent
du Canada à la mode et ça fait que on ne
fait pas une négociation juste sur une
industrie quand on fait une chose
globale comme comme le nouvel Alena il y
a beaucoup d'invités de marques à ce
dîner
son goût rouge j'exagère mais à peine
qui était quelqu'un de politique
non non
politiques
justement vous exagérez pas vraiment en
fait
non c'est parce que on avait
l'impression que c'était une souvent le
cerveau politique derrière toute la
stratégie du gouvernement Trudeau et
après son départ dans toute la
controverse de Jodie Wilson rebours
SNC-Lavalin on a senti qu'il y avait un
creux dans la stratégie du gouvernement
libéral c'est maintenant qui est fort la
chef de cabinet qui est devenu la seule
et unique vraiment broad droit de Justin
Trudeau depuis le départ de jerall boat
qui est un fait qu'il a aussi ce soir on
a essayé de l'intercepter tout à l'heure
lorsqu'elle est arrivée ça pas été
possible elle elle n'est pas attirée
comme un aimant devant les caméras de
ces jours-ci parce que elle a été
vraiment au centre je vous dirais de la
tension depuis quelques jours quelques
semaines même parce que les parties
d'opposition essayer de la faire
témoigner en comité parlementaire sur
l'ingérence chinoise et il y a eu de la
résistance intense de la part des
libéraux avant qu'il plie et accepte de
la faire témoigner en comité
parlementaire plus en avril donc ça
c'était
un sujet dont on n'a pas beaucoup parlé
aujourd'hui je me demandais à quel point
la visite du président Biden
parviendrait à éclipser toute cette
question de la gérance chinoise qui qui
est un véritable boulet pour Justin
Trudeau depuis plusieurs jours ça a été
une journée plus tranquille de ce
côté-là pour Justin Trudeau mais j'ai
pas l'impression que le sujet
est mort pour autant l'opposition va
revenir à la charge professionnelle je
précise aux gens qui voient des avions
là ils sont pas à l'aéroport ils sont
ils font quand même pas le dîner
officiel au hangar de l'aéroport
international d'Ottawa c'est qu'ils sont
au Musée de l'aviation
Ottawa pendant que on va indiquer aux
gens s'il vous plaît d'aller s'asseoir
on va demander aux gens d'aller
s'asseoir monsieur Blanchard convient de
voir qui est un avant-plan qui était le
représentant de du Canada l'ONU Bob Ray
et là j'ai vu enfin on voit un certain
nombre de personnes connues Madeleine
donc c'était
il y avait le jeu c'est à qui être
invité dans la communauté artistique
aussi on nous parle de Charles la
fortune qui est souvent évitée dans les
dans les événements qu'on a vu passer
Grégory Charles je voulais dire mais
Charles la fortune aussi mais Grégory
Charles je voulais dire était là
qui avait été invité aussi au
funérailles de la reine souvenez-vous il
avait joué du piano avec Justin Trudeau
ça avait donné lieu à une soirée dont on
avait parlé dans les médias notamment
britanniques le comme étant peut-être un
faux pas ça a été mais il est encore
invité assez grands événements et je
suis pas certaine que ça vraiment ennuie
à juste un truc d'eau au bout du compte
il y aura des performances musicales
plus tard d'ailleurs j'en profite pour
vous dire que Anne-Marie va suivre à 19h
là je vais vous demander de nous dire ce
qu'ils vont manger là après six heures
en Inde d'analyse politique savante j'ai
le droit de vous demander qu'est-ce
qu'ils vont manger ce soir parce que
représentatifs des plats qui viennent un
peu partout du Canada
en fait c'est ça ça fait des heures que
je trans j'ai ma feuille dans les mains
Patrice me demandant est-ce que vous
allez finir par me demander ce qu'ils
vont manger et voilà ils vont manger
du thon
de la contexte alors on parle justement
des mecs qui sont représentatifs de la
culture culinaire canadienne des maîtres
traditionnelles que aussi canadien donc
du thon de la côte Est pour aller en
croûte de celle de cèdre et d'algues ils
vont manger de une côte de bœuf braisé
de l'Alberta un pavé de pommes de terre
yukong gold des carottes rôties au miel
de fleurs sauvage gâteau mousse au
bleuet sauvages à l'érable du Québec
donc voyez-vous on essayait de
représenter les différentes parties du
pays avec des spécialités culinaires
locales pour essayer d'épater la galerie
et pâté de Joe Biden aussi avec ce repas
pour lui est-ce que nous espions vous
ont dit ce qu'on allait boire j'imagine
la vallée au Canada
je peux vous dire que le président
américain ne boira pas parce que s'il y
a quelque chose que lui et son
prétesseur ont en commun c'est qu'il ne
boivent pas d'argent et Joe Biden ne
touche pas à l'alcool en aidant parti
pour des raisons personnelles de graves
problèmes d'alcool dans la famille de
chacun oui effectivement monsieur baiden
ne boit pas une goutte et
voilà mais dans cette salle il y en a
quelques-uns
ok alors revenons on est prêt de la
conclusion de notre de notre partie
quand il va décoller monsieur bouche et
Monsieur bouche mon dieu mais monsieur
Biden il va se dire je commence avec
vous Raphaël puis tour de table après il
va se dire j'ai fait une bonne action
j'ai été parce que il aurait pu ici et
là mettre un peu de pression sur
certains dossiers il a il a décidé de ne
pas le faire effectivement je voudrais
que probablement une motivation
fondamentale est-ce que Monsieur Obama
n'avait pas lorsqu'il s'est permis de
décocher cette fameuse flèche à laquelle
on a fait référence toute la journée
lors de son allocution Parlement en 2016
c'est à dire que Monsieur Biden à
l'instant de garder un fond
occidental uni oui de façon très
générale face aux autocraties il a dit à
plusieurs reprises depuis le début de
son mandat que le 21e siècle en soirée 1
de confrontation fondamentale entre les
autocraties et démocraties mais de façon
beaucoup plus spécifique dans le fameux
conflit en Ukraine évidemment dans
lequel on est opposé l'Occident et
largement opposé à la Russie donc c'est
très très semblable
veut dire que les Américains attendent
ça ils vont en payer la majeure partie
remarquer mais bien il attendait que le
Canada
se joignent à cette modernisation là ça
semble être accepté donc il part pas
complètement les mains vides de d'Ottawa
et
rassurez-vous pas rassurer puis en même
temps il est parti sur et en même temps
il part avec capitale de de bonne
volonté puis de bonne foi qui est
toujours utile avec un partenaire
commercial alors une visite comme ça
c'est c'est de l'argent en banque aussi
l'argent moral mais toujours comme ça
justement
gardons en tête que Monsieur Baden était
arrivé au Canada plus populaire que les
monsieur Biden ont pris des Canadiens à
faire à Paris que tout au moins sa cote
de popularité va pas avoir baissé après
la journée d'aujourd'hui comme Michel a
mentionné oui il y a un aspect qui est
important pour lui là-dedans il est
arrivé au Canada plus populaire vous
dites il est plus populaire au Canada
qu'aux États-Unis en fait les deux
choses sont vraies il est plus
populaires
qu'il est à la maison et il est plus
populaire au Canada auprès des Canadiens
que les Justin Trudeau ah oui d'accord
ok Madeleine
donc on leur a entendu cette visite
populaire que l'été
quelques minutes de retard moi j'ai
l'impression que deux ordres
tout va bien aujourd'hui les violons les
petits oiseaux mais quand même on disait
pourquoi le président américain ne se
précipite pas plutôt au Canada quand
même
oui il y avait eu cette rencontre
virtuelle Joe Biden a dit bon j'ai eu du
mal première rencontre officielle en
virtuel avec le Canada mais je voyais
des images je m'en souvenais plus là je
m'en souvenais mais j'avais oublié que
les leaders avaient des masques dans les
dans leur salle respective ça donne pas
du tout le même rapport ni le même
impact que ce qu'on a vécu aujourd'hui
Joe Biden a quand même pas Laura qui
avait Barack Obama lorsqu'il était venu
en visite en 2009 si je ne m'abuse on
n'a pas vu Joe Biden se rendre dans un
café dans le marché bye manger des
biscuits donc il y a pas eu ce benful il
y a pas eu ce contact avec la population
qui avait été remarqué et dont on parle
encore des années plus tard ici à Ottawa
il y a encore les biscuits Obama à
Ottawa mais en même temps j'ai
l'impression que effectivement il y a eu
un contact politique qui s'est bien
passé et si Barack Obama même à l'époque
lorsqu'il avait fait son discours en
2016 le Parlement il avait passé des
messages il avait dit dépenser plus en
défense ces messages-là ces petites
tapes sur les doigts elles ne sont pas
venues de la part de Joba que des câlins
aujourd'hui nous visite calin merci
beaucoup à vous trois merci à toutes
l'équipe en régie toute l'équipe depuis
midi on se retrouve nous l'Union on se
laisse sur les images RDI poursuit bien
sûr cette couverture avec Anne-Marie au